المكتبات سيئة وقليلة ومتباعدة وضعيفة
غير فقر الكتب والأنشطة الموجودة فيها
40% من المكتبات ما تقبل إناث
يعني 40% من مكتباتك لا تستقبل نصف الشعب
أطلقنا عليه منصة «رفوف»
أي شخص يمتلك أي كتاب
يسلمه لهيئة المكتبات، وهيئة المكتبات راح تُتيحه
من خلال المنصة إلكترونية لأي شخص يطلبه بشكل مجاني
فقط يدفع رسوم التوصيل
فأنا أعتقد أنه مشروع طموح جدًّا
لكن الأرقام ليست طموحة أبو ناصر
من أي ناحية؟
وهل هذا أدّى إلى عزوف مجموعة من السيدات
اللي يبغون مساحة خاصة
فيهم يبغون يأخدوا راحتهم
هذا سقراط من ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
استضيف قادة التحول، وقادة الأعمال
وقادة الرأي، ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الدكتور عبدالرحمن العاصم
الرئيس التنفيذي لهيئة المكتبات
إي نعم، أنا مثلكم كنت أظن أن الموضوع ما يهمني إطلاقًا
إلى أن جلست معهم، وسمعت مشروعهم
وشعرت بأن فيه شيء جميل جدًّا
قاعد يصير في هذا القطاع
وحبيت أننا نوثقه ونشاركه معكم
تكلمنا عن تاريخ موجز للمكتبات
ودورها في الماضي أول مكتبات في السعودية
أيش كانت التحديات، ليش أغلب مكتباتنا
كانت غير فعالة، وعدد الزيارات أقل من المعدلات العالمية؟
لدرجة أنهم أول ما استلموا هذه المكتبات، قفلوها كلها
و بدأوا العمل على النموذج الجديد
اللي يسمونه بيت الثقافة أيش فكرة بيت الثقافة؟
أيش مكوناته، وكيف استطاعوا أنهم في أول نماذجهم
يحققون عدد زيارات يفوق اللي لذي كان يتحقق من
كل المكتبات مجتمعة طوال السنة؟
حققوه في شهر واحد، وكانت تجربة صراحة
جدًّا مميزة، تكلمنا عن نقاط قوتها
وتكلمنا عن نقاط ضعفها
وتكلمنا عن مبادراتهم الأخرى لتعزيز
سهولة وصول المجتمع للقراءة وللكتب
تكلمنا أيضًا عن مجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء
اللي أكرمونا فيها مثل: ساعة عمل المكتبات؟
مثل: الفرق بين دورهم، ودور هيئة الأدب والنشر؟
استعرت كتاب، والمكتبة اللي برجع لها تقفلت وين أودي الكتاب؟
المكتبات الخاصة وملاكها وكتبهم
كيف ممكن يتعاونوا مع الهيئة؟
إلى آخر أسئلتكم الثمينة، هذه الحلقة برعاية شركة «صفا»
أما الآن أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله، أبو ناصر شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يحييك، الشرف لي طال عمرك
نبغى تسولف لنا أبو ناصر عن كشتة الدقلة
طيب، أنا شخصيًّا أعشق البر، ولي تجارب كثيرة في
طلعات البر في مراحل عمرية مختلفة يمكن
أطول فترة جلسناها في البر تقريبًا واحد وعشرين يوم
ماشاء الله
هذه كانت عام 1415
كانت في روضة نورة تقريبًا تسعة أيام
والبقية في شعيب حريم
وعندي العزبة كاملة يعني عندي الخيمة وعندي
الماطور وعندي عدة الطبخ، وعندي كل شيء
ففي الإجازة الماضية اقترحت على
العيال وأسرتي أننا نطلع في نزهة برية
لكنأنتم كشتة صدق في ناس يروحوا
مخيم جاهز بعماله بأموره، أنتم كشتة صدقية
لا، كشتة صدقية دقينا الخيمة
وشغلنا الماطور، وبدأنا نشتغل على ترتيب
الخيمة وأخذنا ليلتين كانت جدًّا جميلة
حتى بالنسبة لأفراد الأسرة
الأطفال على وجه التحديد أنا أعتقد
أنها راح تكون في ذاكرتهم لوقت طويل، وحتى الآن
كل ما شافوا الجوزين، قالوا خلونا نكشت
ولكن من وقت إلى وقت أنا أكشت طلعاتي
كثيرة طلعات البر، واللي يعرفني عن قرب
يدري أن ما يمر أسبوع إلّا أكون كاشت في أحد الـ...
في أحد البراري القريبة من الرياض إذا
كان فيه إجازة أو فيه وقت طويل الواحد يبعد شوي
ففيها متعة صراحة وفيها برضو تجارب
اليوم كثير من التجارب
خاصة بالنسبة لفئة الأطفال، وفئة الشباب
يحتاجون إلى تجارب
يحتاج أن يعمل، ويحتاج أن يعرف كيف يرتب أموره
يحتاج يعرف كيف ينظم وقته في اليوم
في البر تنظيم الوقت يختلف لازم تقوم الصبح
إذا تبغى تعيش التجربة تبغى
قرص الجمر، وتبغى الحليب، وتبغى...
لازم تقوم الصبح ما ينفع تقعد إلى الظهر نايم
فكانت تجربة الصدق جدًّا جميلة
وبما أنك تجولت في أكثر من مكان واحنا
الآن في موسم مكشات
أيش أجمل بقعة كشت فيها في السعودية؟
والله شوف أنا ما أبعد عن الرياض وضواحيها
في أكثر من الرياض، الرياض طبعًا أو
منطقة الرياض فيها كثير من الرياض الموجودة
سواءً في الشمال روضة النورة، وروضة الخفس
لا يا أبو ناصر أبي أفضل مكان
يعني بنسبة لك خيار رقم واحد، إذا جئت تكشت
والله في الشمال، روضة الخفس
الشمال روضة الخفس
إي
أيش يقال لها المنطقة هذيك؟
هي من أطراف الروضة لكنأنها ما هي
داخل الروضة، فهي جامعة ما بين الـ...
الآن محمية مغلقة صح؟
إي، الآن مغلقة صحيح
لكنأيش يميزها؟
يميزها أنها تجمع ما بين أنها فيضة والرمل
والهدوء، وقريبة للرياض هذه الثلاث أشياء
بالنسبة لي هي الأهم
كم ساعة؟
تقريبًا ساعة وثلاثين دقيقة من الرياض
ما شاء الله
احنا من عالم الكشتات إلى عالم المكتبات
اللي ما أدري أيش القاسم المشترك بينهم
لكن احنا اليوم سعداء أبو ناصر نكسبك
الله يحفظك
ضيف كرئيس لهيئة المكتبات، الهيئة اللي هي
ضمن إحدى عشر هيئة تحت منظومة وزارة الثقافة
وكانت تأسيسها أصلًا مُفاجئة
لأن الكثير من الناس يشوفون هذا
القطاع قاعد يموت، وقاعد يضمح حتى الأرقام عالميًّا
مو فقط عندنا، عالميًّا نشاط
المكتبات قاعد يتراجع بشكل حاد
سواءً عدد الزيارات أو عدد المكتبات
قبل ما نسولف عن الهيئة ودنا تسولف لنا عن
القطاع نفسه، وعن هذه الصناعة من بدايتها
ودخولها إلى السعودية، والمراحل
اللي مرت فيها بعدين سولف عن الهيئة
طبعًا شوف، قطاع المكتبات
في المملكة العربية السعودية يعتبر من القطاعات
اللي لها تاريخ طويل
لما نتكلم عن مراحل الدولة السعودية الأولى
والثانية والثالثة
كلها شهدت نهضة في مجال العلم والمعرفة
والثقافة، ونتيجة لهذا ظهرت المكتبات
لهذا المكتبات تعتبر حالة مرتبطة
بحاجة المجتمع، هي تظهر إذا كان فعلًا في
احتياج في المجتمع، لكن لما نأخذها تاريخيًّا
فهي ظهرت في الحضارات القديمة، يمكن أقدم مكتبة
على وجه التاريخ اللي هي مكتبة الإسكندرية
في الإسكندرية، وفي الحضارة الفينيقية
وبعدها ظهرت مكتبات ثانية والمكتبات الإسلامية
دار الحكمة، وبيت الحكمة، وفي العصر الإسلامي
يمكن وجود الحرمين الشريفين ساهم في ظهور
مكتبات إسلامية، يمكن مكتبة الحرم المكي الشريف
اللي موجودة إلى الآن وهذا من
الأشياء المهمة جدًّا هي تعتبر من أوائل
المكتبات الإسلامية
تقريبًا أنشأت في عام 161 هجري
وما زالت موجودة، وبالعكس دُعمت
في عهد الملك عبد العزيز
في عهد الملك عبد العزيز تم تغيير اسمها
إلى مكتبة الحرم المكي الشريف
وتشكيل لجنة للعناية بها، ورُصدت لها
أول ميزانية، بعدين طبعًا استمرت في النهضة
لما نأخذها تاريخيًّا بعدين استمر...
الدرعية كمثال، الدرعية
كتب التاريخ تؤرخ أن الدرعية كانت عبارة
عن جامعة لطلبة العلم في عدد المكتبات
الموجودة فيها في الدولة السعودية الأولى
وكان أول مكتبة عامة، هي طبعًا كانت مكتبة خاصة
للإمام محمد بن سعود، وأتاحها للعامة
بعدين في الدولة السعودية الثانية في نفس
التطور في الدولة السعودية الثالثة كان
الوضع أكثر
اهتماما بالمكتبات
ولهذا في مرحة توحيد الملكة السعودية ظهرت
العديد من المكتبات من ضمنها الانواع
الاخترى للمكتبات المكتبات البرلمانية كمثال
في عام 26 وافق الملك عبد
العزيز على أن يقوم مجلس الشورى
عام 26 هجري ميلادي عام 1826
وافق الملك عبد العزيز على أن يقوم مجلس
الشورى بإنشاء مكتبة وشراء كتب
وفهارس وصحف فكان فيه رعاية
من ثمانية وتسعين سنة
تقريبًا
في نفس الوقت
تم إنشاء مكتبة مكة المكرمة في عام
1939 مكتبة الظهرانكا مكتبة متخصصة في عام
ولكن كان هناك أكثر من جهة تشرف على
المكتبات الشيء
التعقيب عن السؤال عندما تقول المكتبات
تفاجأ الجميع بإنشاءها يمكن أن أعود إلى
الخطة الخامسية الخامسة
كان فيه توجيه صريح بإنشاء هيئة تولى تنظيف
قطاع المكتبات في المملكة العربية السعودية
بسبب أن هذا القطاع كان يدار من أكثر من
جيهة رئاسة العاملة لعائلات الشباب رئاسة
العاملة لتعامل البنات
وزارة التعليم أو وزارة المعارف في وقتها
فبالعكس أنا أعتقد أن إنشاء
هيئة المكتبات كان ضرورة وملحة
احنا نجيها الهيئة لكنأنا نسأل أفهم المشهد
في السعودية
أنواع المكتبات أنت الآن ذكرت أمثلة أقدمها
صحيح
يعني الجهات هذه المرجعية بعدين موضوع
الثقافة والإعلام كانت آخر مرحلة هي الجهة
التي تشرف على القطاع بشكل عام أم لا؟
صح تاريخياً
كانت المكتبات، خلنا نقسمها إلى أنواع أول
حاجة خلنا نقول المكتبات الجامعية
وهذه نطاق عملها مع الجامعات ووجدت
كمكتبة علمية في عام 1949 في عادة الملكة
عبد العزيز بعد إنشاء قليل الشريعة في مكة
لها تاريخ طويل
في المملكة السعودية بالإضافة إلى أن تخصص
المكتبات والمعلومات يعتبر من أقدم التخصصات
الأكاديمية في الجامعات السعودية دخل تقريبًا
عام 1394 في جامعة الملكة عبد العزيز ثم
توسعوا لها أكثر من جامعة
المكتبات الوقفية النوع الثاني وهذا في
الغالب كان يناط إدارته بوزارة الشغل
الإسلامية ودعوة الإرشاد وأيضًا هذا يعتبر
له تاريخ طويل في المملكة العربية السعودية
النوع الثالث اللي هو المكتبات المتخصصة وهي
تكون متخصصة
في موضوع معين لخدمة غرض بحثي وهذه أيضًا
كانت موجودة من عهد الملك عبدالعزيز مكتبة
أرامكو وانشأت في عام 1927 المكتبات العامة
هي التي انتقلت إختصاصها لأكثر من جهة وهي
أيضًا كانت من المكتبات
القديمة من ضمن المكتبات القديمة مكتبات
رياضة السعودية وهذا وافق الملك عبدالعزيز
على افتتاحه في عام
1949 تقريبًا
المكتبات العامة انتقلت كانت هي تتبع لوزارة
المعارف بعدين انتقلت مع توزيرات اقتصاد
وزارة المعارف وزارة التربية والتعليم وزارة
التربية بعدين انتقلت إلى
وزارة العلام في عام 1226
بعد انشاء وكات الوزارة لشؤون الثقافية
واستمرت بعدها انتقلت
إلى هيئة العامة للثقافة في عام
2017 وبعدها انتقلت إلى وزارة الثقافة بعد
إنشاء وزارة الثقافة في عام 2018 هذا
تقريبًا هو المكتبة الوطنية وهي طبعاً
انشأت في عادة الملك فهد في عام 1410
تاريخياً جميع أنواع المكتبات موجودة
في المنطقة السعودية ومارست جورج
يمكن مكتبات الجامعية واضحة داخل نطاق حرم
الجامعة وتخدم بشكل أساسي الأكاديميين وطلاب
في الجامعة المكتبات الوقفية أو الخاصة هذه
عادتها مرتبطة بأشخاص هذا مفهوم ما ليس واضح
هو الفرق بين المكتبة العامة، والمكتبة الوطنية
أيش الفرق بينهم، وأيش عندنا...؟
طبعًا المكتبة الوطنية
على مستوى العالم هي مكتبة وطنية واحدة في
كل دولة وهي معنية بحفظ تراث الأمة
و لها اختصاصات
اختصاصاتها ببساطة لو حماية
و الحفاظ على الناتج الفكري أو الانتاج
الفكري الوطني من خلال ثلاث
عناصر تمكين رئيسي والتي
في حالة السعودية هي
المكتبة الملك فهد وطنية
مكتبة الملك فهد وطنية وهذه المكتبة طبعا
لها تاريخ طويل يمكن بدايتها
طبعًا كانت عبارة عن اهدام من أعيان مدينة
الرياضة للملك فهد
وكان في البداية مخطط أنها تكون مكتبة عامة
لكن الملك سلمان وجه أنه عادت دراستها لتكون
المكتبة الوطنية للملكة العربية السعودية
وفعلًا صدر نظامها في عام 1410 كمكتبة وطنية
ومعنية بنظام الإيداع القانوني وهذا النظام
الذي يحمي ويحافظ على الانتاج الفكري
السعودي من خلال الزام المؤلفين بإيداع نسخة
أو نسختين من كل عمل أيضًا إيداع نسختين من
ما يقوم أو ما يألفه السعوديين خارج المملكة
بالإضافة إلى جمع الكتب
والمصادر التي تتحدث عن المنطقة السعودية
فهذه المكتبة فيها كل ما أنتجه السعوديون
في السعودية وخارج السعودية أو ما أنتجه
الآخرون عن السعودية كله موجود في المكتبة
التملك فهدوة وطنية التي تعتبر
المكتبة الوطنية لحفظ إرث الأمة
صحيح وما
في لها واحدة منها
ما في
لها واحدة لكن هل
و بالتالي جميع ما ألفوا السعوديين في
خارج المملكة موجود هذه طبعا
حسب وضع المكتبة الملكية الوطنية الآن وهي
في مرحلة تحول اليوم مكتبة الملكية الوطنية
و يعول عليها شيء كثير لكن في المقابل كان
لها أدوار كبيرة جدًّا يمكن صدر نظام ويعطيها
المكتبة ملك فايد ووطنية وهذا كان نظام جدًّا
مهم في وقتها اللي هو نظام حماية التراث
المخطوط وهذا النظام صدر في عام 1422
و كان جدًّا مهم اليوم المنكبة السعودية بحسب
الدراسات فيها أكثر من 160 ألف مخطوط أصلي
فبالتالي الحفاظ على هذا التراث المخطوط
كامل همية بالمكان وهذا النظام أعطى
فهذه مكتبة ميك فهد
وليست تحت شرافكم لا أبدًا
هي مرتبطة مباشرة بدوان مجلس الوزراء
وهي اللي مؤخرا عين الأمير فايصر بن سلماء
رئيس المجلس أمنا صحيح
و المكتبات الوقفية والخاصة ليست تحت
شرافكم والمكتبات الجامعية ليست تحت
شرافكم أجل ليس المكتبات اللي عندكم
لا هو طبعا
ليوم لنا فيها المكتبات عندنا دورين رئيسيين
الدور الأول تمكين وتنمية القطاع وهذا يشمى
جميع أنواع المكتبات نعمل اليوم مع جميع
الأنواع التي ذكرتها المكتبات الجامعية نعمل
معها
لتطويرها لأن وضعها الوضع الحالي ليس الوضع
المأمول فبالتالي الهيئة لها دور في قضية
التمكين وقضية الدعم وقضية تنمية القطاع بما
يكفل تحقيق العائد منه مكتبة الملكة الوطنية
لنا دور كبير خاصة خلال السنتين الماضية
بعد تكليف سمو الأمير بدر وزير الثقافة
كقائم بأعمال مجلس الأمنا عملنا على موضوع
المكتبة الملكة الوطنية والحمد لله
تم الانتهاك من الكثير من الملفات
والتي الآن يقودها صاحب السمو الملك الأمير
فياصل بن سلمان والذي نتوقع أن المكتبة
المنقوعة الوطنية خلال الفترة القادمة ستكون
لها دور كبير جدًّا وستنتقل من مكان إلى مكان
وهذا هو الشيء المأمول فيه بناء على
مكانة المنقوطة السعودية وبناء على عدد
الانتاج الفكري السعودي الموجود
المكتبات الوقفية أيضًا في جهة
قد تكون الآن هي اللاعب الرئيسي مجمع الملك
عبدالعزيز المكتبات الوقفية وهذا طبعًا انشأ
نتيجة حف المكتبات الوقفية التي كانت موجودة
في المدينة المنورة وحتى الآن حتى لما نشوف
الأعداد الموجودة فيها من كتب
التراث أكثر من 16 ألف مخطوط موجود في
المجمع المكتبات الوقفية خلّى أخذها لك
بشقّين الشقّ الأول هو المقتنيات النادرة
اللي الآن غير قابلة للتداول وهذه تشمل
المخطوطات والوثائق وغيرها وهذه نقطة جدًّا
مهمة هذه طبعًا تعتبر تراث كبير يجب
المحافظة عليه اليوم كل المكتبات الوقفية أو
في الغالب المكتبات الوقفية فيها مجموعة
كبيرة من المخطوطات يعني أعطيك مثال مكتبة
مكة المكرمة فيها 3000 مخطوط مكتبة
ابن عباس فيها تقريبًا 1000 شيء مخطوط تكلم
عن المكتبات الوقفية الأخرى في القصيم أو في
الشمال أو في غيرها فهذه الآن أن نعمل على
يعني يجاد حلول وفي مشروع يدرس الآن
من خلال هيئة المكتبات بالشراكة مع اللاعبين
الأساسيين والهيئة العامة للأوقاف والجهات
الثانية للمحافظة على هذه المكتبات الوقفية
و يعادت حوكمتها
اليوم الإشكالية في المكتبات الوقفية
أنها ضايعة لا يجب أن تكون مع هيئة المكتبات
وفيها وقف وفيه مجلس نظارة وفيه مصادر
موقوفة فبالتالي أعتقد أنها تحتاج إلى جهد
بالنسبة لمكتبات متخصصة أيضًا اليوم المكتبات
المتخصصة أغلب الجهات الحكومية والمؤسسات
الخاصة تمتلك مكتبات متخصصة لخدمة الزوار
والموظفين من خلال أمداد المعلومات أيضًا
لنا دور في قضية التشريعات والتنظيمات فهيئة
المكتبات جاءت استجابة لتنظيم هذا القطار
يمكن تركيزنا في الهيئة
خلال سنتين الماضية كان على المكتبات العامة
لأنها كانت موجودة، وانتقلت من وزارة الثقافة والإعلام
ووزارو الإعلام إلى وزارة الثقافة بعد إنشاء الوزارة
فهذا كان السبب ومجال
التركيز فكل ما سبق هي المكتبات التي تحت
إشراف الجهات الأخرى لكلكم دور تتعاون معهم
الجاي هو الحديث عن
المكتبات العامة التي تحت إشرافكم
المباشر ولا يوجد غيركم لها علاقة
لا ، هناك مكتبات تدار من خلال اقطاعات أخرى
عندنا مكتبة الملك فاهد العامة في جدة و
ليست الملك فاهد الوطنية
هذه تدار من جامعة الملك عبدالعزيز
عندنا مكتبة الملك عبدالعزيز
العامة في رياض أيضًا تدار من مؤسسة الملك
عبدالله وعندنا مكتبة مركز ابن حاس تيلي
تدار من المركز
إلى هيئة المكتبات ولكن تدعم
وتشجع على إنشاء المكتبات
خلو وخلنا نمسك أبو ناصر المكتبات اللي
نقلت من وزارة الثقافة
والإعلام سابقًا إلى وزارة الثقافة بشكل
جديد تحديدًا هيئة المكتبات
صرفني عن واقع هذه المكتبات هي حدود شيء و
ثمانين مكتبة صح؟ تقريبًا اثنين وثمانين مكتبة
خصوصًا أنك أنت أبو ناصر كنت جزء من
وزارة الثقافة والإعلام سابقاً في الوكالة
التي كانت معنية بهذا الأمر أنت تعرف واقعها
لما نقلت لكم ودنا نسوي تشخيص لهذه
المكتبات أيش تحدياتها أيش اللي عملتوا عليه
طيب أنا أعتقد
هذه نقطة جدًّا مهمة وجديرة صراحة
بالاستعراضها لأنها فعلًا تحكي عن واقع
وبناء على هذا الواقع تم اتخاذ قرارات
طبعًا 82 مكتبة التي كانت موجودة
50% منها هي مباني مستعجرة
والخمسين المتبقية هي مباني لا أقول متهالكة
لكن يعرف المهندسين أن أي مبنى بعد 40 سنة
يعتبر مبنى متهالك يحتاج إلى عادة فبالتالي
هذا من ناحية المباني عندما تجي من ناحية
التجهيزات كانت تخلو من جميع التجهيزات
التقنية لا وجود لشبكات الإنترنت
لا وصول إلى الإنترنت لا مصادر رقمية
لا وجود وضوح في البنية المؤسسية
لإرتباطات المكتبة طريقة إدارتها وحوكمتها
نماذج التشغيل الموجودة فيها
كل هذه العوامل ترتب عليها أن تكلفة الزيارة
بالنسبة للمكتبات ارتفعت يعني متوسط تكلفة
الزيارة اليوم في المكتبات العامة
يمكن تتراوح بين أربعة دولار
كما المكتبات في اليابان وتوصل إلى تسعة دولار
في المكتبات الأمريكية فلو نأخذ المتوسط
تقريبًا سبعة دولار تكلفة زيارة الفرد للمكتبات
العامة في المملكة العربية السعودية
تكلفة زيارة الفرد 521 دولار
دولار؟
دولار
وهذه تُقاس بأنه تحسب تكلفة المكتبة
عدد الزوار ويقسم عليهم
فلان عدد قليل صارت الكلفة عالية جدًّا
عالية جدًّا لاحظ برضو أنه لما حسبت التكلفة
هذه ما حسب فيها التكاليف الرأسمالية حسبنا
فقط التكاليف التشغيلية وجميع الموظفين
الخدمات التي تقدم فكان هناك
توجه كيف نتعاطم مع هذه
المكتبات خاصة أنه اليوم الوزارة عندها رؤية
جديدة ودائما في المشاريع التطويرية
تحتاج إلى أن تبدأ قويا اليوم المكتبات
انتشرت في بداية الذقاء وفيها عزوف
فبالتالي لا يمكنك أن تبدأ ضعيفاً يجب أن
تبدأ بمفهوم جديد يجب أن تبدأ برؤية جديدة
يجب أن تبدأ بخطة
قادرة على الاستدامة سواء الاستدامة المالية
في قضية تعزيز إرادات المكتبة بنفسها أو حتى
استدامة قبال الجمهور على المكتبة اليوم لا
أريد أن أستثمر مبالغ ضخمة في مكتبات تشتغل
مدة سنة أو سنتين وبعد ثلاث سنوات نرجع لنفس
الإشكالية اللي وقعنا فيها في السنوات الماضية
اليوم نهدف المكتبة تكون قادرة على جلب الزيارات
تكون قادرة على إحداث فرق داخل المجتمع
تكون قادرة أيضًا على تعزيز إيراداته
بما يضمن تقديم خدماتها في أي التقلبات
فهذا كان هدفنا في المشروع
لكن قبل ما أدخل في الهدف لو بشوف جزء من
تحديات القطاع أنه مثلًا
عدد المكتبات العامة لكل مليون فرد
احنا نتكلم في المرحلة الحالية موضوع دول
المكتبة تراجع كثيرا لأنه لا يوجد مصدر
المعرفة اليوم
ولكن على الأقل الفترة الماضية التي كانت
فيها حراك واهتمام ودعم من الدولة نرى أنه
في السعودية عدد المكتبات لكل مليون فرد
هي ثلاث مكتبات صحيح لو
نقارنها مثلًا مع فنلندا سنجد
158 158 مكتبة لكل مليون
نقارنها بالمملكة الوطنية 64
مكتبة لكل مليون إذا كنا نقارنها مع
فلندا فسنجد 158 مكتبا لكل مليون إذا كنا
نقارنها مع المملكة المتحدة فسنجد 64 مكتبا
لكل مليون أمريكا 28 مكتبا
اليابان 26 مكتبا إذا كنا نتكلم عن المنطقة
شي مشابه
مصر مثلًا 11 مكتباً لكل مليون نسمة بينما
السعودية
تتحدث عن ثلاث مكتبات فقط أيش سبب أنه ما كان
عندنا وفوقها عدد زيارات أقل يعني إحنا
عندنا معدل 60% ما عمرهم طبوا
المكتبة وفي حدود
يعني 10% فقط اللي يزورونها
خمس مرات أو أكثر فأنت تتكلم على
عدد قليل وإقبال رعيف وما هو السبب؟
طبعًا هناك أكثر من سبب
أنا أتكلم بناء على المعطيات وبناء على أول
شيء عددها لم يكن هناك رؤية واضحة فيما
يتعلق بالمكتبات وهمية وجودها بالنسبة
لمتخذ القراءة في وقتها ودورها أيضًا في
مؤشرات ازدهار المدن اليوم مؤشرات ازدهار
المدن أحد المقاييس وهو عدد وجود المكتبات
يمكن مقياس الأمم المتحدة البنية التحتية
وتشمل نصا عدد المكتبات العامة
فما كان فيه رؤية واضحة ما كان فيه تصور
واضح عن المكتبات بالإضافة إلى نقطة نعتقد
أنها جدًّا مهمة في قضية التكامل بين المؤسسات
اليوم أنا في الهيئة نطمح أن نصل إلى عدد
كبير في المكتبات لكن نجاحنا ليس
غير مرتبط بتعاوننا مع الآخرين
ألا ترون يا بناصر أن التشريعات والتنظيمات
كانت عائقة عندما تجد
أن 40% من المكتبات لا تقبل إناث يعني أن
40% من مكتباتك لا تستقبل نصف الشعب
هذا أول ثانيا موضوع ساعات العمل
ساعات العمل حقيقية المكتبات
لا تتناسب أبداً مع
متطلبات الحياة وسالفة أني أنا لما خلص
دوام أروح أقرأ أو أبحث محتوطة كأنها دوام
ساعات عمل لموظفين المكتبة ما يستفيدونها
للموظفين ففي تنظيمات كانت تعيق استفادة
الناس زائد طبعًا وضعها المتهالك مثل ما أنت
وصفه بطريقة منفرة أروح أقرأ في كافي
أو نسلي وأجمل من أن أقرأ في مكتبة
هو طبعًا اللي تفضلت فيه صحيح ولهذا حتى في
أرجع للخطة الخمسية الخامسة في عادة الملك
فاهد أشارت على نقطة وكانت من ضمن النقاط
التي تم الإشارة لها في قرورة
إصلاح قطاع المكتبات كان من ضمنها السماح
بدخول النساء كانت مضمنة في الخطة الخمسية
موجودة نصاً فهذه التشريعات
يمكن نشوفها اليوم على مستوى كثير من
القطاعات قطاع الرياضة كمثال اليوم
الإقبال على حضور المباريات
ومختلف الألعاب حادثات جدًّا بسبب التشريعات
فاليوم التشريعات تدعمنا في الهيئة ما عندنا
أي مشكلة في التشريعات
لكن أنا أرجع وأقول لكم ما كان في رؤية
واضحة عن همية المكتبات
توسع فيها بدون هدف واضح
كان في مشروع قدم أعتقد في 1429
لا علاقة بإعادة النظر فيه في المكتبات
العامة التي كانت تتبع الوزارة الثقافة
والإعلام إضافة إلى نقطة جدًّا مهمة نعتقد أنه
بعض الحياة في بعض القرارات التي تتخذها
كلها تأثير سلبي اليوم نتكلم عن المكتبات
المدرسية المكتبات المدرسية إلى عام 1428
كانت تسمى بالمكتبات المدرسية ثم صدر قرار
تحويلها إلى مراكز مصادر التعليق فأنت فصلت
اليوم عن تنشئة الجيل على موضوع المكتبات
أنا يمكن نقطة أحب أن أشير لها أنا بدأت
حياتي بوظيفتي كنت مدرس وكنت أدرس مادة
المكتبة ومصادر البحث في
المدارس اشتغلت سنة في القصيم وبعدها جئت
للرياض فكنت
على علاقة جيدة مع الطلاب في قضية المكتبة
وقضية الليول القراءة وحتى أنا أذكر
في أحد الثانويات في الريار
أصبحت المكتبة بالطلب من كثرة العدد
للطلاب اللي كانوا يبون يجون أيضًا كان فيه
ربط ما بين المادة التعليمية وما بين مصادر
المعلومات قدرنا بجهود ذاتية أن نعزز
مواد المكتبة أو مصادر المكتبة
بكتوب وعنوين لها علاقة
بتخصائص الطلبة في المرحلة الثانوية
أنا اعتقد أن هذا التشتوت هو اللي قاد
الى اللي وصلنا لها بالإضافة إلى نقطة جدًّا
مهمة برضو حتى في قضية التوسع في المكتبات
أنا أعتقد أن أمر مهم في دراسة السوق
اليوم ليس الهدف أن أفتتح مكتبات
أو أن أستعجل مبنى وأضعه في مكتبة الهدف
فعلًا هل هناك عائد
قادر على تقديم خدمات نوعية يمكن أن يكون
نقطة مهمة في قضية اليوم التقنية
اليوم هناك عزوف اليوم القطاع يتغير في بعض
الحالات ليس نتيجة أن المكتبات هي التي
تتغير بنفسها نتيجة الظروف اليوم نتكلم عن
نشر الأكتروني احنا نتكلم عن المكتبات
الجامعية اليوم معظم دور النشر الأكاديمية
لا تنشر ورقي تنشر الأكتروني فبالتالي أنت
ملزم أن تتحول نتكلم على مستوى أنظمة
التعليم التعيم عن بعد اليوم فتحة فاق جديدة
للوصول الاكتروني نتكلم اليوم حتى عندنا في
المنطقة السعودية مؤخرا بعد
برنامج تنمية القدرات البشرية والقرارات
المتسارقة يمكن آخر قرار صدر البارح في قضية
تخرج المرحلة الثانوية ولم يحقق المواصلة
فكل هذا يعني تعطي انطباع أننا نعيش في فترة
فعلًا المكتبات فيها جدًّا مهمة وبالتالي
لا بد أن ينضلها بوضوء مختلف تمامًا
وما مشروعكم طالما أنها مهمة وما مشروعكم
في مسألة المكتبات وما قمتم بفعله في
82 مكتبات التي ورثتمها
طبعًا مشروعنا إن شاء الله نقول انه مشروع
طموح مشروع يلبي احتياجات طلعات المجتمع
اليوم الحمد لله اننا نعمل وفق
هدف استراتيجي واضح الهدف هذا أن ندستورنا
اليوم في الهيئة أنه استراتيجية الوطنية
للثقافة المستمدة من رؤية المملكة 2030
اليوم نطمح أن يكون عندنا مكتبات بمفهوم
جديد وفعليًّا بدأنا
بهذا المشروع واليوم مكتباتنا تسمى بيوت
ثقافة هي عبارة عن منصات ثقافية
وصول للمعرفة هذا جزء من مهامها
لكن تنمية القدرات البشرية خلق التواصل
التنمية الثقافية التنمية المجتمعية هذه
أهداف رئيسية فيها
لماذا منصات ثقافية ؟ اليوم توجهات
بأندية الهوات اليوم في المملكة تقريبًا بحسب
آخر عصيات منصة هاوي عندنا 717 نادي هوات في
أكثر من 205 من الهوايات هذين يحتاجون
منصة هذول وين بيمارسون نشاطاتهم
لكن توك أبو ناصر قبل دقيقة تقول أخطأنا في
حق المكتبة يوم غيرنا اسمها وسمناها مصادر معرفة
الحين انتم على أول شيء بدأت
فيه مشروعنا حولنا المكتب إلى بيت ثقافي
لا ، خلني أوضح لك، اليوم لما تروح إلى أي
مبنى راح تحصِّل البيت ثقافي مثلًا بأحد رفيدا
مكتبة أحد رفيدا العامةن ما حاولنا نطلع
ونغير تغيير كامل، لكن أننا نبغى نغير الموضوع أو
الفكرة الكاملة عن المكتبة أنه مجرد
مكان للوصول للكتب أنت سميتها مخزن كتب
أو مخزن المكتبة هي مخزن كتب بينما
البيت الثقافي مكان أكثر حياة
أكثر حياة
و ما هي مكوناته
مكوناته طبعًا مكتبة
بأشكالها سواء موجهة للطفل أو الموجهة للشاب
أو الموجهة للبالغين مسرح مساحات
فردية مساحات جماعية معامل ومختبرات
معمل تصوير ومعمل تسجيل يعني تقريبًا كل
دعم أو كل القطاعات الـ 16 في وزارة الثقافة
راح تكون إن شاء الله موجودة
معنا داخل بيت الثقافة
وهذا يفترض أن يكون هو الشكل الجديد
للمكتبات العام صحيح ليس فيه
الشكل السابق لا أنتم قفلتم كل 82
قفلنا كل 82 لكن هذا الشكل الجديد لن
يكون موجود في كل المكتبات بأي حال
لكن سيكون موجود في المكتبات الكبيرة اليوم
عندنا أربع نماذج
فالنموذج هذا سيكون في المكتبات الكبيرة
والمكتبات المتوسطة وعندنا برضو خطة نهج
الوصول يعني اليوم خطتنا وتوزيعنا الجغرافي
مبني على نهج ليوء كم من الوقت يستقلق
المستفيد للوصول للمكتبة في المراكز
السكانية الكبيرة 20 دقيقة
في المراكز السكانية
المحافظات والأطراف 40 دقيقة فعندنا نهج
واضح في عملية الوصول
و جزء منه سيكون متاح في المكتبات
الصغيرة والمتلات الصغار فهناك نماذج
مختلفة وليست نموذج واحدة وهذا هو الوضع
الطبيعي اليوم
حتى على مستوى جميع دول العالم أنت لا
تقدر تقديم نفس الخدمات في جميع المكتبات
لكن هناك خدمات تقدم بناء على دراسة السوق و
حجم المدينة اليوم لا أقدر قارن مدينة
مثلًا عدد السكان فيها بالملايين في محافظة
أو مدينة عدد السكان لا يتجاوز 100 ألف
دعونا نمسك الأربعة التصنيفات التي ذكرتها
كم عدد المكتبات بحلول 2030 التي يفترض
أن تعملون عليها بهذا الفكرة الجديدة
بالأربع فئات
153 مكتب إن شاء
الله
كم منها بيت ثقافي
عندنا 8 مكتبات كبيرة و22 متوسطة
فعندنا 30 بيت ثقافي 30 بيت
عندنا ثمانية مكتبات كبيرة
وثمانية مكتبات متوسطة
فعندنا ثلاثين بيت ثقافي ثمانية بالحجم
الكبير يعني حتى لا تغطي
مناطق المملكة الثلاثة عشر
لأن مناطق المملكة فيها تباين
يعني أنا أعطيك مثل بسيط نتكلم عن منطقة
الباحة عدد السكان بحسب الإحصائيات تقريبًا
450 ألف بينما في
مثلًا منطقة الرياضة أو في مدينة الرياض
عدد السكان يصل إلى 4 مليون في جديا
في رياض؟ أكثر رياض 9 مليون أو
8 مليون في مدينة الرياض فأكيد
أنه سيكون هناك تباين بحسب
لكنأقصد الحد الأدنى أنه كل منطقة من ناطق
المملكة توفر فيها بيت ثقافي بالنموذج الذي
تفضلت فيه حتى يكون فيه فرصة لكل سكان
المملكة أن يحظموا بهذا التجربة أنا أفهم
أنك لا تضع 10 فروع في الباحة
بينما تضع 10 فروع في الرياض لكن على الأقل
هناك فرع واحد بالنموذج
المميز الذي ذكرته أنت تكون
في الباحة هذا سيكون موجود في كل مناطق
لكن عددها ثمانية كيف؟
المتوسطة جزء من المتوسطة
والكبير هي نفس الفترة فالثلاثين
هذه هي الموزعة فأنتم ملتزمين
بأن كل مناطق المملكة الثلاث
عشر فيها
بيت ثقافي بالنموذج الجديد
المسرح والمستوى تمام أو لا؟
دعونا نسميها مكتبة بمفهوم بيت الثقافة
أجل لا نخرج من التغيير المسلم
مكتبة في مكتبة الثقافة وهي المتعدد
الأجزاء التي تشرحته صحيح هذا
التزام في كل مرة قبل ممنك
بإذن الله تعالى
كم منها خلصتوا حتى الآن؟
حتى الآن طبعًا ، عندنا ثنتين تشغيل تجريبي
وإن شاء الله سيكون قريباً في أحد رفيدة وفي
الدمام وعندنا تقريبًا في السنة هذه
ست مشاريع بدأ العمل عليها نتوقع أنها تنتهي
في الربع الثالث أو الربع الثاني
تغطي تقريبًا خمس من مناطق المملكة وعندنا
أيضًا السنة هذه إن شاء الله المشروع
لاستكمال بقية المناطق نفتتح فيها
المكتب المفهومة لجديد بيت الثقافة
بكامل مكوناته فهيكون غطينا جميع
مناطق المملكة العربية السعودية
لكنأبو ناصر يعني سامحني
3 سنوات و4 سنوات من تأسيسكم وثوقم
2 سنوات في مرحلة التجريب
مرحلة التجريب أنتهت
مرحلة تشغيل التجريب مرحلة تشغيل التجريب
مكتب 2 في خلال 3 سنوات يعني مو معقول
لا أنا أعتقد أنه معقول جدًّا لأنه نتكلم
عن قطاع مختلف تمامًا قطاع رأس مالي قطاع
تشغيلي موازنات عالية
نماذج تشغيل مختلفة فبالعكس أنا أشوف لنا
وضع طبيعي جدًّا ولكن
التحدي بالنسبة لنا اليوم ليس قضية الثلاث
سنوات هذه الثلاث سنوات كانت عبارة عن جمع و
تحليل بيانات أعطيك من ضمن الأشياء التي
عملنا عليها خلال السنة الماضية
اليوم عندنا الكثير من الأصول الحكومية
غير مستفاد منها ويمكن أن أكبر مثال عليها
هي المراكز الحضارية التابعة
لوزارة شرطن البيديا والقلويسكا
هذا جميل وصراحة نتعاون
معا بذلنا جهد وقدرنا بني قاعدة بيانات
كاملة عن جميع المراكز الحضارية الموجودة في
المملكة عددها احداثياتها جاهزياتها
مستوى الإنجاز فيها وقدرنا نشتغل
مع الجهات ذات العلاقة يمكن أول مشروع راح
يطلع إن شاء الله اللي هو واحد الملك سلمان
اللي وقعنا شراكة مع أمانة مدينة الرياض في
الانتفاع من مدة 25 سنة فقضية
تعظيم الإفادة من الصول الحكومية كان
بالنسبة لنا موضوع جدًّا مهم ليس قضية بناء
اليوم البناء يعني عارف أنه فيه الرؤية جاءت
واضحة فيما يتعلق بتعظيم الإفادة من الصول
الحكومية فبالتالي كان نستهدف أين نقدر أن
نطلع بشكل سريع وفي نفس الوقت نقدر أن
نوفر اليوم لو طلعنا مع
المراكز الحضارية على مستوى فقط 20 مكتب أو
بيت ثقافي حجم الوفرات التي سنوفرها
على ميزانية الدولة تقريبًا 8 مليار
زايد السرعة زايد السرعة أغلبها مواقع قائمة
زايد السرعة النقطة الأهم أيضًا هي التشارك
مع بين المؤسسات الحكومية في قضية المشاريع
الثقافية اليوم لا تقدر أن تعمل بخلال ما
هي الحالة ونرى الآن على كافة القطاعات
في مجال القطاع الرياضي وفي مجال القطاع
السياحي تكامل بين المؤسسات وبين القطاع
الحكومي والخاص أعتقد أن هذه هي التحدي
التي عملنا عليه خلال ثلاث سنوات ماضية
وخلال السنتين، لا نقدر أن نقول
ثلاث سنوات، يمكن أن نقول سنتين
كورونا أنت لا تحسبونها لا،
لأن تأسيس الهيئة كان في فبراير 2020
فعلى بما تكون فريق العمل، على
بما تم الإنتهام بأستراتيجية
استراتيجية فعندما تكون فريق
العمل عندما تم التنمية الستراتيجية
استراتيجية ما انتنى منها تقريبًا
في شهر 3 من 2021
تعرف اليوم ما تقدر تشتغل بدون ما يكون عندك
استراتيجية وأهداف ومؤشرات
فنقول سنتين هي التي فعلًا
كانت في عمرها على الرغم من النقطة المهمة
أقولها وهي تدعم كلامنا في السنوات
إن استراتيجية تطوير المكتبات العامة طبعاً
كانت من ضمن مبادرات وزارة الثقافة ولا
تعني أنها مع تنشية استراتيجية واعتمدت
قبل إنشاء هيئة المكتبات
وعتمدت وزير الثقافة في ديسمبر 2019 ففعليًّا
أنتم جاهزين وخاصين من المفترض أن تروا أكثر
من
في نفس موضوع المكتبات بمفهومها الجديد كبيت
للثقافة أنا صراحة لم أكن مستوعبا ولم أكن
أفهمها لأنه عندما زرتك وعرضوا الزملاء
نموذج مكتبة أحد الخيزة
الحقيقة أنه مهما حاولت أوصف الموضوع
أجمل مليون مرة من اللي أنا كنت أتوقع
والنجاح هو في إحياء المكان صراحة أنا لا
أظن عندنا عائق لنبني أماكن جميلة نقدر
بناءها ونسبق لنبنيها ونبنيها وليس بتحدي
التحدي هو كيف تقنع الناس كيف تجذبهم وكيف
تحفزهم لأنهم يأتون
وما حدث في هذا المكان غير عادي أنا سأترك
لك مسؤولية أن توصف للناس ما الذي حدث في
هذا المكان وما هي الأنشطة وما هي الدورات
عدد المسجنين وعدد الزوار
لأنها فعلًا حراك غير عادي
حسنا أبسطلق لم أجيب السؤال لكن سأعود
لأن سؤالك صراحة يلامس شيء
كبير حق السنتين؟ حق السنتين
أنا حين عفيتك من حرج أنت بيرجع
تحت لا لا
لا بالعكس بالعكس
لأنه ثلاث سنوات ومكتبتيه
طبعًا ما حد بيقتنعها لا بالعكس
يعني اليوم في منتجات
أطلقتها الهيئة يعني الهيئة
حنجيها إي
لا لكنأن هذي جزء من خطة التحول إي يعني
اليوم أنا ما أقدر أتكلم عن أني أوكي أنني
وقفت خدمات المكتبات في شكلها التقليدي
لكن في المقابل اشتغلت على الخدمات التي
تلبي احتياجات الناس فيما يتعلق بالوصول إلى
المعرفة من خلال أكثر من مشروع يمكن مشروع
مناول ، مشروع مسموع مكتبات متنقلة و
هذا يتحدث عنها ، لكن بعدما خلص مشروعكم
الأساسي والأكبر هو المكتبات
بالذات من المفهوم الجديد كبيوت للثقافة
صحيح بعدها سنتكلم عن المبادرات الأخرى
لأنها ليست بنفس الوزن يظل هذا هو مشروع
الأساسي لكن هذه المبادرات الأخرى كانت
لتغطية الفراغ خلال السنتين
على مال ما تظهر مشاريعنا الرأسمالية و
مشاريع الأصول كان فيه بدائل قدمت للمستفدين
للإستفادة منها لكن أعود إلى أحد الرفاية
تاريخيا أعتقد أنها أول مرة تحدث
عدد الزوار خلال 38 يوم وصل إلى 12 ألف
عدد كبير جدًّا جدًّا جدًّا
أنا أسترجع لك ببناء على
خبرتي السابقة في زاوية الثقافة والإعلام
يمكن مجموعة المكتبات لم تصل إلى هذا العدد
أذكر كثير من المكتبات التي طلبنا تقارير
وراجعناها أن عدد زيارات في شهر لبعض
المكتبات تصل إلى 22
وبعض المكتبات 17 17 شخص
أنتم هناك 12 ألف
12 ألف في 38 يوم يقدم أسبوعية ما لا يقل عن
20 برنامج ما بين برنامج تدريبي
أو ما بين ورشة حمل في مختلف المعرفة
في تنمية القدرات في مجال التقنية مقدمة
مقدمة مقدمة أردت أن
أمثل بناصر محددة وما بالضبط قدم لهم؟
أنا أحببت أن استعمتم بخبرات المجتمع المحلي
نفسه وأرادوا أن يكون له أهل الديرة
و قدموا ورش لأهل الديرة
قدمت فيها برامج في التقنية استخدام
Microsoft Office كمثال الـ Excel
PowerPoint Word قدمت فيها
ورش أورش عن الرسم باستخدام أدوات معينة
قدم فيها ما يتعلق بالاستثمار وكيف أنك
تحافظ أو ترسم ميزانيتك
قدم فيها أيضًا فيما يتعلق بتعزيز العادات
القرائية قدم فيها اختياراتك واتحديد
اتجاهاتك وميولاتك القرائية فهي منفتحة على
جميع الموضوعات الخاصة وهذه نقطة يمكن أشرخت
لك يا أخوي عمر اليوم أن في أي مكتبة أو في
أي مشروع أن نسوي دراسة قبلية نجتمع مع أهل
المنطقة أو المدينة ونسمع منهم ونسمع هم
ما يريدون وليس نفسنا حسناً عندنا توجهات
فيما يتعلق ببعض القضايا المهمة لكن الأهم
أنه كيف أن هذا المجتمع يؤمن أن هذه المكتبة
هي مصدر ملهم له ولأبناء ومكان للمتعة
عندنا مستهدف ثاني برضه وهذا أيضًا من أشياء
لعشراتها لرؤية المملكة العاشرين وثلاثين
اللي هو دمج المجتمعات اليوم نتكلم عن
العمالة الموجودة في المملكة السعودية من
المقيمين مختلف الجنسيات مختلف المهن اليوم
علاقتهم الثقافية حاجة إلى مكان يمارسون فيه
نشاطاتهم بحق إلى خلق علاقة جيدة ما بين
الثقافات فهذا أيضًا دور راح نلعب فيه وليوم
عندنا توجه برضه وهذا من الأشياء مهمة جدًّا
في مكتباتنا الحديثة هذه في عقد
ندوات ودورات بلغات مختلفة عندنا
دراسة الآن تجربة الدمام وحضر فيدر معرفة
أحلى الجنسيات
الموجودة فممكن يكون عندنا بكرة مستضيفة وش
ساعات الدوام للمكان هذا؟ طبعًا ساعات الدوام
إلى الساعة 10 في الليل طبعًا فيه طراب
يعني ما تسكون ثنتين في الظهر مثل
لا لا لا شغل أول أسموح
لرجال ونساء بالأعمار ما في سقف أبداً
الجنسيات ما في سقف فهي مفتوحة للجميع
في قضية الفصل بين الجنسيات أنا أعطيك دور
هيئة المكتبات اليوم إلى وقت قريب كان بعض
المكتبات تفصل بين الجنسين
إلى وقت قريب جدًّا جدًّا جدًّا
لكن هيئة كان لها دور في إغلاق هذا الموضوع
فاليوم لا يوجد مكتبة تفصل فهذا أحد أدوار
هيئة المكتبات في تطوير كفاءة القطاع
وهل هذا أدى إلى عزوف مجموعة من السيدات
اللي يبغون مساحة خاصة
فيهم ويبغون يأخذوا راحتهم
لا لأنه في الأخير المكتب فيه مساحة مخصصة
لكناليوم نتكلم عن تجربة
و كلنا إلى وقت قريب قية شخص مر بمثل هذه
التجارب اليوم لما نروح لأي مكتبة أو تروح
لأي مكان يقولك هنا قسم الرجال هنا قسم
النساء طيب والأطفال شو وضعهم هذا وضعهم في
مكتب المكتب ويقولون لهم أنه يجب أن يكون
هناك مكتب وفيه مدخل رجال ومدخل نساء وهنا
خدمة وهنا خدمة فهذه أصلًا حتى فيها تكاليف
وما عاد فيها متعة
تجاربنا كثيرة كانت في وقت سابق، كان في عُزوف
عن حضور بعض المناسبات أو الفعاليات
بسبب قضية الفصل، اليوم لا، كل المكتبات
الاستوديو تفعل والمسرح هل تفعلت في أحد رفيدا؟
لا إلى الآن ما تفعل
ليش؟
مش لسبب، لكن في خطة تشغيلية واضحة
أعتقد التفعيلة راح تكوت خلال الفترة القادمة
لكن المسرح فُعّل، وورش العمل فُعّلت
المسرح؟
المسرح فُعّل، في ندوات ومفتوح الآن للاستضافة
في نفس الوقت...
في عروض مسرحية أو...
لا، إلى الآن ما قُدم فيه عروض مسرحية
لكن في طلبات وصلت للبيت الثقافي
في أحد رفيدا بطلب المسرح
لتقديم فعاليات معينة، وشغّالين عليها
أيش علاقة شركة «علم» في الموضوع هذا؟
ما لها علاقة، «علم» شركة مشغلة فقط
مشغلة؟
مشغلة، وحتى التجارب اليوم، خلنا نأخذ على مستوى
تشغيل المكتبات، وهذا من التوجهات الحديثة في
تشغيل المكتبات العامة بسبب
تخفيض التكاليف وتعزيز الإيرادات.
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية اليوم في
شركة تُدير أكثر من خمسة وتسعين مكتبة عامة
النتائج اللي حققتها نتائج مهولة
أول حاجة في عدد الزيارات
ارتفع عدد الزيارات بمعدل 25%
الوقت اللي يمضيه الزائر داخل المكتبة
ارتفع من نصف ساعة إلى أربعة ساعات
فاليوم القطاع الخاص، وهذا أيضًا من اختصاص
هيئة المكتبات، اللي هو تشجيع القطاع الخاص على
الاستثمار في المكتبات في شركة «علم» مشغل
تمتلك من الخبرات، وتمتلك من الدراية فنعمل
معهم ونتمنى، إن شاء الله، تنجح تجربة كأول تجربة
على مستوى المملكة في قضية إدارة وتشغيل
القطاع الثقافي من قبل القطاع الخاص
وفي مقهى جوا البيت الثقافي أو المكتبة هذه؟
المفترض أن فيه
لسّا ما بعد
إي، في عروض الآن يعني عرض وطلب
لكن المفترض في، وفي مطعم برضو
فدور الشركة المشغلة أنها تجيب هذه
الروافد التجارية، وتحاول تغطي
مصاريف المكان بحيث يكون مستدام
صحيح، حتى فيما يتعلق بالفعاليات وتنظيم الفعاليات
حتى ما يتعلق بتأجير المساحات
كل هذه من الأهداف الأساسية اللي خلتنا نفكر
بطريقة كيف أن القطاع
يُدار من خلال القطاع الخاص
لكن المؤكد أنه لن يكون من مصادر دخلكم
رسوم دخول، ولّا رسوم على الورش هذه
لأنه اثنا عشر ألف ألف هذول ما جاؤوا
إلّا لأنك فاتح الباب مجانًا
أول ما تبدأ تحط رسوم، وتضيق عليهم
أنت تكون حرمت جزء من المجتمع
أنه يستفيد من هذا الأشياء
لا طبعًا، ما راح يكون في رسوم
أول شيء بالنسبة للعضويات هي عضويات مجانية
لكن في عضويات متميزة
اليوم أغلب المكتبات حتى على مستوى العالم
العضويات بشكل مجاني، لكن تسمح مثلًا
بإعارة سبعة كتب في الشهر، فأنا ممكن أعطي
عضوية مميزة أسمح لك بأربعة عشر كتاب
فترة الإعارة واحد وعشرين يوم في العضوية المميزة ممكن
أرفعها إلى واحد وخمسين يوم
فهي خيارية بالنسبة للـ...
لكن الحد الأدنى متاح للجميع بشكل مجاني
نجي إلى موضوع الورش، وموضوع هذه
لا، هي مجانية إلّا في حالة واحدة إذا كان في
مساحة استؤجرت من المكتبة من قبل
قطاع خاص أو من قبل مؤسسة حكومية
وتقدم دوراتها بشكل يعني بالرسوم
فهذا يعني خاص فيهم، لكن احنا ملتزمين في الهيئة
بتقديم ورش، وبتقديم برامج موجهه لجميع فئات المجتمع
بشكل مجاني على مدار العام
إذا كان الممول وزارة الثقافة، والمشغل «علم»
ليش نحتاج هيئة في النص؟
تطرح الوزارة مناقصة
تشغيل ثلاثين أو أربعين أو 100 مكتبة
وتجي علم وتأخذها وتشغلهم، وين قيمة
المضافة للهيئة في هذا القصة؟
طبعًا القيمة المضافة للهيئة في قضية أولا
رسم الاستراتيجيات الخاصة بإدارة القطاع
بشكل كامل بشكل كامل سواء المكتبات العامة
أو الخاصة أو إلى آخره الشيء الثاني فيما
يتعلق بالتشريعات والأنظمة والمراقبة اليوم
على مستوى جميع القطاعات
كثير من القطاعات اللي نشوفها اليوم تشغل عن
طريق القطاع الخاص هل يعني الغاء للجهة
الحكومية المسؤولة؟ لا، بالتأكيد بالعكس
أنا أعتقد أن مثل هذه الممارسات
تعطي الجهة مساحة أكبر
مو بس دور تنظيمي ورقابي
تنظيمي وبحث عن الفرص
اليوم لما نتكلم عن قطاع المكتبات
وهذه من ضمن الأشياء اللي عملنا عليها
خلال الفترة الماضية اليوم حتى في
قضية فعاليات هيئة المكتبات
هي لها ارتباط بنظريات التعليم، وبنظريات التعلم
اليوم أننا ما نبغى الطفل مجرد أنه حضر فعالية
لا، اليوم نبغى الطفل يطلع، وهو مُكتسب مهارة
المهارة هذه تنمو
يعني راجعنا جميع الإحصائيات
والدراسات اللي نشرتها وزارة التعليم فيما
يتعلق مثلًا باختبار كفاءة القراءة الدولي
اللي تشارك فيها المملكة، واللي حققت في
2021 نتائج شوي متقدمة
مقارنة بـ 2011 و2016
عرفنا بيانات جدًّا ملهمة، ومهمة في قضية
الطلاب الأكثر تفوقًا في القراءة هم من الفئة
هم من الفئة ذات الدخل الاقتصادي مثلًا
المرتفع أو المنخفض، هم من الفئة اللي عندهم
مكتبة في البيت
فلا، عندنا مشروع ضخم في قضية تنمية
القدرات البشرية اليوم نأمل
أن القراءة والمعرفة والوصول تصبح سلوك
وهذا اللي نراهن عليه، وهذا اللي أعتقد أنه
هو اللي راح يحقق جميع مستهدفاتنا
اليوم لما نشوف كثير من ريادة الأعمال على
مستوى العالم لما نتكلم عن...
أعطيك مثل بسيط، في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
المكتبات العامة تساهم في خلق تقريبًا أكثر
من مليون وخمسمائة وظيفة سنوية من الوظائف الحديثة
كيف تخلقها؟ من خلال تطوير الكوادر لبشرية
من خلال دعم رواد الأعمال
والمؤسسات الصغيرة والمتوسطة
أننا بكرا نتأمّل ونطمح أننا مكتباتنا وبيوت الثقافة
أنها تكون هي الملجأ لرواد الأعمال
وهي الملجأ للحصول على المعلومات
هي الملجأ لفهم السوق، ولمعرفة المجتمع
معدّل إنفاقه على التقنية
معدّل إنفاقة على الثقافة
معدّل إنفاقة على الترفيه، وعلى الرياضة
وبالتالي تقدر تنطلق
نأمل أنه اليوم، وكلنا نتفق تمامًا
اليوم المهارات التي يمتلكها الأشخاص هي اللي تقود
اليوم كثير من الناس عنده إنترنت في البيت
وعنده وصول من خلال الجوال وغيره
لكن مو قادر يوظف التقنية لخدمة حياته
سواءً اقتصاديًّا أو اجتماعيًّا
اليوم عندنا مشروع ضخم يتعلق بتعزيز الوعي
للمعلومات كيف تقدر توظف التقنية لخدمة حياتك
وهذا من ضمن نتائج الرؤية اليوم النشاط الذي
نرى اليوم النشاط التعليمي والنشاط الثقافي
و الرياضي الناس بدأت تفكر في كل شيء الناس
بدأت لديها طموح عالي الناس بدأت تفكر
أن هذا الوضع أن نريد أن نطلع فوق قيادة
سيدوية العهد كانت ملهمة جدًّا فاليوم نفعية
المكتبات نأمل أن نكون مظلة
تخدم جميع قطاعات الدولة
ومازلنا في الحديث عن تجربة أحدر رفيدة
أنتم نجحتوا في الأصعب
وأنا أعتقد أن ما رأيته عدد الزوار ونوع
الأنشطة والبرامج والورش اللي قُدّمت شيء فوق
التوقعات، وإذا استمريتوا بالطريقة هذه
أنا أؤكد لك أنه راح يكون في أثر
ثقافي على المجتمع لا يوصف
فهو الجزء الأصعب سويتوه، الجزء الأسهل
اللي هو تصاميم حلوة ملهمة محفزة
هذا ما صار، وهو الغريب لأنه
كان معكم وقت
هذه ما هي منشئات قديمة ورثتوها وقاعدين تعدلوها
هي منشئاتجديدة، وزارة الثقافة كل مشاريعها
ذات جودة تصميمية تفوق العادي، وتفوق الخيال
لما شفت المكان جدران بيضة إضاءة بيضة
حسيت أني في عيادات
مكان ما يعطيني شعور الإلهام اللي اليوم ناس
تروح تختار مقهى عشان تقرأ فيه لأنه
والله المكان بصريًّا ممتع
وين كانت مشكلة، طبعًا هي مو سيئة عشان ما أحد
يفهمني غلط، هي ليست سيئة لكن لا توازي
المتوقع من وزارة الثقافة ومن هيئاتها
ومشاريعها اللي دائمًا تعودنا أن تكون شيء مميز
طبعًا يمكن الحكم من خلال الصور قد يكون
لكن أنا أقدر أن أقول لك أن المكتبات
والتصاميم روعي فيها أعلى المعايير
لكن أنا أتفق معك كان ينقص بعض العناصر
الثقافية اللي تكون موجودة وهذه طبعًا تأخرنا
فيها لأنه كنا نستهدف
كنت تطلعت على صور أحد الرفيدة، أننا نستهدف
الأعمال الفنية من أبناء المنطقة أنه نقدر
نجيب أعمال فنية
من أي مكان لكننا نستعد في تحضير أعمال فنية
من أبناء المنطقة لكي يكون هناك ارتباط
فالذي نقدر أن نوعده في الهيئة هو أنه
سيكون مكان ثقافي سيكون مكان ملهم
سيكون هناك عناصر جذب فيما يتعلق بالتصاميم
لكن هذه المباني لم نورثها
بشكل جيد مبنى أحد الفيادر
الأعمال الانشائية التي تمت فيها تقريبًا
تفوق تكلفتها أكثر من سبعة عشر مليون
هدم وإعادة بناء وإعادة ترتيب الأمور وإعادة
فتح المساحات
فعدنا تصميم المبنى داخليا بحسب
استراتيجيتنا فهذا كان جدًّا
مش أمر سهل، وهذا ينسحب على كل المكتبات اللي
نعمل عليها، أننا ما نتكلم عن التصميم الخارجي
التصميم الخارجي يمكن يسوينا فيه عناصر بسيطة
وكانت جميلة لبساطة خارجية جميلة
خارجية جميلة نتكلم على من جوه من
جوه أنا اتفق تمامًا معك لا بد أنه يغذى
بعناصر ثقافية لوح تحاف خطوط
يمكن بعد زيارتك
على طول اتخذنا إجراءات وهذا الشيء الجيد في
الأخير أنه يمكن لهينا في شغلة
أكبر فيما يتعلق بالتفعيل
وهذا الصح، وبيض الله وجهكم
لكن كان عندنا مثلًا جانب قصور فيما يتعلق
خاصة التغذية البصرية الداخلية
اليوم بعدما
التقينا معك على طول تواصلنا مع كثير من
القطاعات داخل الوزارة المهتمة
مركز الأمير محمد بن سلمان للخط العربي
نشوف كيف نقدر...
هيئة الفنون البصرية
أعتقد، إن شاء الله، أننا قادرين على الإبداء
وقادرين، إن شاء الله، على أنه نستمر
لكن استمراريتنا هي مرتبطة برضو بالتفاعل
اللي نتوقع من المجتمع اللي نتوقع من
المجتمع أنه هذا المكان يعني مش مكان
للزيارة الموسمية مكان
للمتعة الثقافية مكان للتعليم
عادة أسبوعية أو يومية صحيح
يومية أي ونتوقع، إن شاء الله، أن يحدث الفرق
من اليوم إلى نهاية
عشرين أو أربعة وعشرين
راح يكون عندنا ما لا يقل عن تسع بيوت ثقافة شغالة
أعتقد أننا بنكون حصلنا على كمية بيانات ومعلومات
كبيرة سنعمل على إعادة دراستها وتحليلها
فهم أعمق للموضوع
وبرضه تقييم تجربتنا من خلال تفعيل
تشغيل الوصول الثقافي من خلال قطاع خاص اليوم
عندنا أنظمة تشغيل ثانية نعمل عليها تشغيل
المكتبات من خلال المؤسسات
الغير ربحية هنا نتماشى مع
رؤية مملكة 2030 احنا نتكلم عن تشغيل
المكتبات من خلال المؤسسات الغير ربحية وهنا
فيه برضو نتماشى مع رؤية مملكة
2030 اليوم المملكة تستهدف تقريبًا مليون
متطوع بحلول 2030 تصريح معاني وزير
المؤارث البشرية وصلنا إلى 650 ألف
أنا أعتقد أنه راح نصل بعد الرؤية ويكون
قفلنا الرقم أكثر اليوم كيف أنه أفراد
المجتمع يؤمنون بهذا المشروع ويساهمون في
إدارته من خلال العمل التطوعي كيف؟
الجهات ذات العلاقة منصة «هاونة» تدعمنا أيضًا
فيما يتعلق بـ...
أندية الهواة
أندية الهواة ودعم أندية الهواة الموجودة
وتخصيص الأماكن داخل هذه المشاريع
فأنا أعتقد أن مشروع طموح جدًّا
لكن الأرقام ما هس طموحة أبو ناصر
من أي ناحية؟
من ناحية أقصد أنت راح تصل إلى150
153 في 2030
حتى ما غطيت مدن المملكة
وكان في سؤال هنا جميل
غطينا مدن السعودية، نتكلم عن المحافظات
المحافظات ألف وباء
صحيح
هنا في سؤال رائع من أحد الأصدقاء
يقول، ما نبغى أكبر وأضخم نبغى أقرب
عادة المنشآت أو هذه الأماكن
تزداد الاستفادة منها عندما تكون أقرب وسط
الأحياء فهل 153 هو هدف طموحي يغطي
كم في المئة من السكان يكون لديهم وصول
خلال عشر دقائق ماشية إلى هذه الأماكن؟
حسب الدراسة التي عندنا
لو حققت 6% من المكتبة فأنا خدمت 91% من
السكان المقابل السوري فيما يتعلق بالوصول
وماذا تعرف خدمتهم؟
خدمتهم لأنني خدمتهم فيما يتعلق بالوصول
كم أقدر الوصول؟
خلال عشرين دقيقة سيارة سيارة خلال عشرين دقيقة
المفترض أنك تقدر توصل للمكتبة طبعًا
أنا أتفق معك أنه لما نرجع مثلًا اليوم
للمؤشرات الدولية أنه مكتبة لكل 100 ألف
فبالتالي أنا رياض أنا أحتاج تقريبًا
على افتراض أنه خمسة مليون فأنا أحتاج إلى خمسين
مكتبة لكن هل أنا أحتاج إلى خمسين مكتبة كأصول؟
أو أحتاج إلى خمسين مكتبة كخدمات؟
اليوم أنا مناول يعتبر مكتبة بحد ذاتها، مكتبة ذاتية
دامك جبت طاريه، أشرح لنا مناول
مناول، هو عبارة عن جهاز ذاتي يتيح للمستفيد
استعارة الكتاب وارجعه بدون تدخل بشري
عبارة عن جهاز يوجد فيه تقريبًا 375
عنوان مختارة بعناية، تجي أنت كمستفيد تسجل
بياناتك من خلال الأنظمة الإلكترونية
تطلب الكتاب تسحبه تأخذه عندك
في البيت تقرأه، وترجعه للآله
و كم مكينة من هذا النوع موجودة؟
عندنا الآن اثنا عشر
وهي أول مرة تدخل على مستوى الشرق الأوسط
فكانت تجربة جدًّا مهمة بالنسبة لنا
ودخلنا في شراكات مع القطاع الخاص
جميع الأجهزة هذه موجودة في المولات عسى أن
تكون أقرب للناس
فهذا جزء من مشاريعنا اليوم نتكلم عن هذه
المكتبات عندنا تقريبًا
لو ناخذها كمكتبات وهذا
كم تريدون أن تصلون من جهاز
نريد أن نستهدف أن نصل إلى الحد الأدنى الذي
يغطي لما نقول مثلًا مدينة
مليون نسمة  وفيها مكتبة واحدة نبغى تسع أجهزة
على أساس يكون عندي عشر وكنت ماشية مع معيار اللي
هو مكتبة لكل 100 ألف، بالإضافة لنقطة
جدًّا مهمة لما تكثر الأجهزة ويكون فيه
أصل فعملية الأصل اللي عارة واستعارة راح تكون
سهلة ليوم أخدت الكتاب من الجهاز هذا ما
تملزم أنك ترجع في نفس الجهاز أنت ملزم ترجع
في أي جهاز ترجعه في المكتبة نفسها
الخدمة اللي نشتغل عليها الآن
من البيت تقدر ترجعه عن طريق البريد وهذا
سيكون إضافة للمستفيد في قضية إرجاع الكتاب
صرفنا نوياك بناصر عن الفرق بين التجربة
الأمريكية وسورتي بشأن المكتبات
واحدها نجحت وزدهرت واحدها داغما حلت
تجربة الامريكية هي التي نجحت لأنها صارت في
المفهوم الجديد المصادر
أو مراكز مجتمعية أكثر منها مكتبات تقليدية
اليوم على مستوى
الزيارات في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
طبعًا آخر حصالة طلعت عليها كانت في 2019
لم يكن هناك نزول كبير أقل من 1 إلى 2%
وهو انخفاض عدد الزيارات من 2011 إلى 2019
لكن في المقابل ارتفاع في عدد حضور
الفعاليات وارتفاع
في عدد الفعاليات وفي نفس الوقت تنمية
القدرات وتطوير الذات كانت مرة عامة جدًّا
مهمة 65% من المبحوثين في المكتبات يرون أن
المكتبة ساهمت في تطوير وتنمية قدراتهم
55% من الشعب الأمريكي عضويات في المكتبات
العامة وعلى سبيل المثال، تأثرت
تجربة بريطانية في عام 2008 بعد الأزمة
المالية يترتب عليها تخفيض في ميزانيات المكتبات
يترتب عليها إغلاق
عدد المكتبات اليوم تقريبًا عدد المكتبات
الموجودة في بريطانيا يمكن 3600
مكتب مقارنة بـ 17000 في الواقع من تاعدل
أمريكية كثير منها الآن يعاني
ما في صراحة خطة
لأنها استمرت كمكتبة ما تحولت إلى مركز
ما عادة أحد المدن
في اليوكيا كان عندهم مشروع رصده لتقريبًا 12
مليون باوند في قضية إعادة تفعيل
المكتبات كمراكز مجتمعية ترتب عليه زيادة
عدد الزيارات زيادة عدد الفعاليات
ارتفاع معدل الرضا يمكن التجربتين هذه كانت
بالنسبة لنا جدًّا مهمة وملهمة لكن دائمًا
أنا أقول مهما كانت تجارب الدول الأخرى أنت
اليوم في سياقات مختلفة تمامًا اليوم
إحتياجاتك قد تكون هي الأهم
التجربة الأمريكية
محل اعتبار وندرسها ونستفيد منها التجربة البريطانية
التجارب الأخرى، سواءً كانت عربية
لكن اليوم أنا عندي سياقات مختلفة عندي مشاريع
لها علاقة بجودة الحياة عندي مشاريع لها
علاقة بتنمية قدرات البشرية
عندي مبادرات ومشاريع لها علاقة بإثراء تجربة
الحاج والمعتمر كل هذه تصب
وتتطلب مني أن أعمل وفق هذه الاستراتيجيات
و أستفيد من التجارب الأخرى
فقلنا أننا غطينا موضوع بيوت الثقافة أو
المكتبة بشكلها الجديد وقلنا هدفكم 153
مكتبة في 2030 وصرفنا عن أحدر
فيدة وصرفنا عن مناول صحيح
مناول اسم أخذ من أحد الوظائف التي كانت
موجودة في مكتبة بيت الحكمة أنه كان
الشخص اللي يسحب الكتاب، ويعطيه المستفيد
آه حسنًا، من هنا أخذتوا الاسم
فأخذنا الاسم من هذا
حاليًّا في اثنا عشر جهاز لكن
هو التوسع الحقيقي، والكبير راح يكون من خلال
هذه الأجهزة، عشان نحقق الحد الأدنى في الأصول
وهي اللي ممكن نلاقيها
في المحافظات، ونلاقيها في كل مكان
لا، المحافظات طبعًا، إن شاء الله،راح نلاقي لكن
حسب تصنيف المحافظات، محافظة ألف، باء، جيم
اليوم كثير من المحافظات تكون قريبة
صعب أن تضع في كل محافظة مكتبة لكن ممكن
تجي إلى المركز الأساسي
أو المحافظة وتخدم بقية المراكز التي تتبعها
فهذه من ضمن الاعتبارات عندنا وهذا
من الأشياء التي سنخطيها إن شاء
الله وشاهدت عندكم تجربة سمع
أو مسموع مسموع ماهي هذه؟
مسموع طبعًا هو مكتبة صوتية
روعي في تصميمها أنها تحاكي اللي هو كباين
الاتصالات السعودية التي كانت موجودة في
فترة السبعين والثمانيات
الميلادية وهذا طبعًا توجه عالمي لكثير من
الدول بدأت توظف
الكباين الصوتية في أكثر من مشروع فمشروع
مسموع صراحة حصل على
ردود فعل جدًّا جميلة وفي نفس الوقت
عدد المستخدمين عالي جدًّا اليوم آخر إحصائية
من بداية إطلاق المشروع إلى اليوم عدد
المستخدمين وصل تقريبًا إلى 253
ألف مستخدم لماذا؟ جهاز مسموع عجيب طبعا
أعلى المدن جدة معدل الاستمع فيها عالي جدًّا
بعدين الرياض وبعدين المنطقة الشرقية لو
تشرح بشكل مبسط وبناصر طريقة الاستخدام
تقف أمام الشاشة
تضغط ابدأ تختار من العنوان الكتب الموجودة
تختار بحسب الموضوع مثلًا أبغى تنمية
المهارات مثلًا الشخصية، تضغط على الكتب
الموجودة تسمع مقطع تقريبًا مدته إلى خمس ثواني
مختصر الكتاب، جاز لك الكتاب مسح للكود على جوالك
تسمع الكتاب وأنت ماشي
فهو مكتبة مجانية أخذ الكتب...
إذا ملخص الخمس ثواني شوقني
كود ألاقيه تحمل على جوالي وأسمع وأنا مكمل
صحيح
فاللي ما يحبون القراءة
الكتب المقروءة عندهم مكتبة ضخمة من الكتب المسموعة
صحيح
كم عنوان في الجهاز؟
حتى الآن وصلنا تقريبًا إلى 150 عنوان
مجاني؟
مجانًا، أضفنا عليها مؤخرًا
تقريبًا خمسين عنوان باللغة الإنقليزية
وهذه النقطة جدًّا مهمة ومثل نقاش بين الزومب
دائما المكتبة نعرفها كمتخصين
أنها كائن ينمو
لا تقول لي 150 شوي لأنها ستنمو مع الوقت إلى
أن توصل إلى العدد الكبير مثلها مثل المكتبات
الرقمية مثلها مثل المكتبات التقليدية
نقطة جدًّا مهمة برضو في هذه قضية
فأي من الأشياء اللي اطلعت عليها وشدتني صراحة
لما الزملاء يشاركون معي اللي هو
الإحصائيات، أحب أن أدخل بعض التفاصيل أنا أتذكر
المشرف الدراسي اللي كان يشرف علي دائمًا
يقول لي تخيل أنك رقم داخل هذه الأرقام
فأثناء عملية تحليل البيانات وتتعرف على
الرقم الجانبك فأنا دائمًا
يشوفون أني أكون حريص في لما تجي التقارير
أطلع عليها فنات صفحة التقارير
وجد طبعًا أول شيء طبعًا معدلات الاستخدام
تتفاوت من مكان لمكان آخر وهذا مؤشر مفترض
أنه يستخدم بالنسبة لنا أو نستفيد منها في
الحياة أو حتى بالنسبة للباحثين الراغبين في
دراسة قطاع النشر أو قطاع
الكتاب في المملكة السعودية شيء ثاني أنني
أستعرض أكثر الكتب الاستماعية
كما رأيت من ضمن
العرض أكثر الكتب الاستماعية
تفاجأت أنها تتماشى مع الرؤية تطوير القدرات
الرجل الذكي الأب الفقير والأب الغني
كلها تتماشى بالإضافة إلى الروايات والقصص
فهذه تعطيك انطباع وتعطيك تصور كامل عن
توجهات وهذه ستساهم
في تغذية قطاع النشر اليوم أهلية المكتبات
لها دور كبير جدًّا في قضية تحسين قطاع صناعة
النشر وهذه من النقاط التي عملنا عليها خلال
الفترة الماضية يمكن أنا
و كثير من من في عمري ما زلنا نلاقي علاقتنا
جيدة بالكتاب الوراقي
بينما نجد أن الكتاب الاكتروني لا يستهين
بشيء كثير لكن اليوم تلابد أن تشوف التوجه
الحقيقي وين رايح فكان فيه بعض الملاحظات أن
الهيئة تتوجه إلى الوصول الرقمي وتنسى
الجانب الإلكتروني
التوجه إلى الوصول الإلكتروني مهم جدًّا لكن
الإشكالية الآن التي نواجهها خاصة ما يتعلق
بالكتاب السعودي أنه غير متاح بشكل إلكتروني
فبالتالي قطاع النشر لما يعرف أن فيه جهة
راح
تشتري منه هذه النسخ شيء طبيعي أنه سيعمل
على تحويل منتجة إلى
إلى نسخ رقمية وبالتالي أنا سيد مينوى عزيز
صناعة قطاع النشر في المنطقة السعودية وفي
مشاريع طبعًا وهذه النقطة من الأشياء التي
تحسب للوزارة وتحسب للتوجه العام التكامل
بين الهيئات والتكامل بين القطاعات الثقافية
اليوم اللي قاعد يصير على المستوى الوزارة
وحدة من مبادراتكم المهمة أبو ناصر هي تصميم
وبناء مكتبة رقمية للأطفال صحيح وأعتقد أن
هذا فعلًا فعلًا بيكون مغير لسلوك
الأجيال القادمة إذا بدأنا نحفزهم ونشجعهم
القراءة من عمر مبكر أيش أخبار هذا المبادرة؟
طيب بالنسبة للمكتبة الرقمية ومكتبة الأطفال
هي جزء من مشروع كامل وهو منصة الرقمية وهذا
أيضًا أحد المشاريع المهمة اللي عملنا عليها
خلال الفترة الماضية ومن المتوقع تتشين
المنصة خلال الربع الأول بإذن الله تعالى
هذا العام
كان عندنا مشكلة على مستوى المكتبات وما
زالت المشكلة قائمة إلى اليوم لا يوجد
حصائيات عن عدد المستخدمين للمكتبات
لا يوجد حصائيات عن حركة
تداول أو عدة المعلومات كم عدد الكتب التي
استعارت وكم الأفراد الذين استعاروا
لم يكن عندنا إحصائيات عن
الحضور للمكتبات كلها تسجى بشكل ورقي
لم يكن عندنا منصة
أو شبكة موحدة بإمكانك استفادة من جميع
خدمات المكتبات في مغرب سعودية بعضوية واحدة
كان عندنا مشكلة في قضية الفعاليات وهذه قد
تعالج بعدم التواجد في بعض المحافظات اليوم
نطمح أنه أي فعالية تنظم داخل المكتبة أنها
تتاح أونلاين فبالتالي ممكن تسجل فيها
أونلاين فأنا أحضرها حضوريا وأنت تحضرها
بشكل مباشر بنفس الخصائص تمنح لك شهادة حضور
إذا كان في شهادة حضور يسمح لك بالمداخلة أو
المشاركة بالإضافة طبعًا إلى أنه
تكون مصمم بناءً على
الـ Personalization أو السماعة الشخصية
أنك مجرد أن تدخل على النظام يبدأ النظام
يتعرف على احتياجاتك يقدم لك المقترحات
نشتغل الآن على توظيف تقنية الذكاء
الاصطناعي في فوبتنا الرقمية مشروع إن شاء
الله نرى يكون جدًّا جميل
فنطمح إن شاء الله أن هذه المنصة
هي المرجع الأساسي
لجميع المقيمين في المغرب السعودية
من المواطنيين ومن المقيمين في عملية وصول
مصادر المعلومات أيضًا
قبل أن نتحها أن أتحنا الآن أن اليوم عندنا
منصة رقمية أيضًا فيها تقريبًا أكثر من 6000
عنوان بالممكن الوصول لها
هذه كانت نتيجة التحول والإغلاق تقنى مشاريع
بديلة فهي منصة بإذن الله ستكون على مستوى
عالي بالنسبة للأطفال عندنا مشروع ثاني
أيضًا مع وزارة التعليم نجم القراءة سيطلق
إن شاء الله هذا السنة وهذا سيعمل بإذن الله
على تعزيز العادات
القرائية ورفع مستوى الوعي
هل بلقى في تطبيق واحد في الايباد أو في
التابلت الجهاز اللوحي
مجموعة من العنوان الممتعة المشوقة عربي
انقليزي حيث أنه أقدر أقول لعيالي خلوكم
معاها إلى الليل ما يشيء همكم
كم عنوان بيكون فيه؟
طبعًا أنا أرجع وأقول اللي
هو المكتبة كائن ينمو
صحيح
فراح يكون فيها عنوين حتى الآن
البداية بكم؟
البداية حتى الآن المكتبة
الرقمية أعتقد وصلنا إلى حوالي 200 ألف
200 ألف عنوان هذا إجمال المكتبة
إجمالي المكتبة
كم منها للطفل؟
للطفل، إلى الآن لأن
هذا النقص هنا التحدي
الطفل في مرحلة طبعًا في مرحلة جمع
العناوين لا عدد كبير متى تبدأ ؟ لكن أعود
إلى نقطة جدًّا مهمة لأن في الأخير حتى كتاب
الطفل هناك ضعف في إنتاج كتاب الطفل
فبالتالي سنواجه فيها تحدي ولهذا نرى
طقوا الباب على جيرانكم
ما قصروا
جيرانكم هيئة الأدب
ما قصروا واشتغلوا
على مسرعة أعمال لأدب الطفل في نسخة
أولى السنة الماضية، وهذه النسخة الثانية
فبالتالي في مشاريع كبيرة بما يتعلق بثقافة
الطفل نعتقد أننا سنكون جزء من هذا متى
تبدأ المبادرة هذه
مبادرة المكتب الرقمية
اللي جزء منها
هذه، إن شاء الله، الربع الأول راح تُطلق هذا الشهر
تكون عبارة عن أيش، هي موقع؟
موقع مبدئيًّا ويجب عمل الآن
على تطوير التطبيق الخاص فيها
هذه أهم ثلاث مشاريع شغالين عليها في الهيئة
هل في شيء آخر ودك تسولف فيه
ولّا ننتقل إلى أسئلة الأصدقاء؟
فيه مشروعين أعتقد أنها جديدة
أن تذكر اليوم المشروع الأول هو مشروع
المخطوطات يمكن بداية الحديث في قضية
المملكة السعودية ودورها في المحافظة على
التراث المخطوط اليوم في هيئة المكتبات
أطلقنا منصة المخطوطات
فيها حتى الآن خمسة ألاف مخطوط بنصوص كاملة
سنة هذه سيضاف عليها ألف مخطوط وهذه بالممكن
الوصول إليها من خلال البوابة الثقافية
تابعة وزارة الثقافة عندنا مشروع أيضًا
ترخيص تقديم خدمات المكتبات
اليوم عندي ثمانية وعشرين مرخص يقدمون خدمات المكتبات
فيهم تقريبًا ١٢٠ سعودي يعملون في هذا القطاع
وعدد المستفيدين من هذه البرامج وصل إلى
5000 بأكثر من أربعة وتسعين فعالية نطمح، إن شاء الله
أن يكون عندنا برضو عدد أكبر من الرخصين
وهذه ستحل مشكلة تقديم خدمات المكتبات بمعنى
أنك كمستثمر في القطاع وكرائد أعمال في
القطاع ومهتم بقطاع المكتبات يمكنك تفتح
محل وتقدم نفس الخدمات التي يحتاجها
المستفيد من أي مكتبة قضية الإطلاق وقضية
الإعارة وقضية تقديم الدورات
والفعاليات ستكون موجودة اليوم ثمانية وعشرين موزعة في
جميع مدن المملكة فأنا أعتقد أن هذه برضو
من المشاريع المهمة التي أحب أن أشير لها
أنا أختم بمجموعة من أساتذة أصدقاء أبو ناصم
في سؤال يقول
حاليا أغلب أنشطتكم مسابقات وليالي
ثقافية وترفيهية ما في شيء له
علاقة بالقراءة ما تعيقك على هذا؟
لا أعلم يمكن أنه خلط بين هيئتين أو أكثر
لأننا لا نملك مسابقات لا تلقنا
فقط مسابقة موجهة للأطفال في مناسبة
العام الشعر العربي
بقية الفعاليات كلها موجهة للطفل في مجال
تعزيز العدالة القرائية عندنا فعالية
أطفالنا يقرؤون
قدمناها السنة الماضية وقدمناها السنة هذه
مبنية وفق نظريات التعلم والتعليم
فما عندنا صراحة مسابقات
في سؤال جدًّا جميل هنا مرتبط بالتنسيق بينكم
بين المشاريع الكبرى
هل فيه تنسيق للاستفادة من الأصول يعني كل
المشاريع الكبرى القدية
الدرعية البحر الأحمر نيوم
العلا كلها فيها حجم تطوير عقاري هائل جدًّا
أن غريفة في طرف المشروع تخصص بيت ثقافي
تخدمهم أنكم تحيون جزء من مكانهم وتخدمكم
بأنهم شالوا عنكم عب التطوير مثلما حدث في
موضوع الملعب
مثل القدية بنى ملعب أو سيبني ملعب
المشروع وسط جدة راح يبني ملعب الاتحاد والأهلي
شيء مثل هذا هل فيه تنسيق؟
جدًّا تنسيق على مستوى المشاريع الكبرى على
مستوى المشروع المعلن وسط المدينة
موجودين في كل من المشاريع من
الذي قفلت معهم وخلصت معهم؟
والله الجميع تقريبًا قفلنا
معه معتمد لكم موقع في كل هذه
المشاريع موقع في هذه المشاريع
من ضمن الميوثاثة وخمسين؟
من ضمن الميوثاثة وخمسين فنحرص
على إذا جاءتنا مثل هذه المشاريع التي فيها
قصور بالعكس أن نفرح بها ويمكن حتى على
مستوى أرجع أكد على نقطة جدًّا مهمة
وليس عوّل عليها الكثير صراحة في هيئة
المكتبات الشراكة مع وزارة شؤون البيتدير
القراري والوسكان هي التي تحدث نقلة في
المراكز الحضارية
و تمت أول مشروع بدأناه معهم
وهو وحدة الملك سلمان في الرياض
فيها سؤال جميل على موضوع المكتبات الخاصة
اليوم هناك عرف عند الأجيال السابقة كل واحد
عنده في بيته مكتبة إذا توفي
صاحب البيت بلا شوبها الورثة وباعوها أو
تصرفوها أو أتلفوها
هل هناك جزء من التنسيق بينكم وأصحاب
المكتبات أنكم تأخذون الكتب وتضعونها في
البيوت التي تشعرون بها وتحتاجون لها كتب
لم تفكروا في شيء من هذا الموضوع؟ لا ،
طبعًا ، انظروا
المكتبات الخاصة وهذه من ضمن الأشياء
التي تحدثنا اليوم عن السياقات أن تعمل في
ضل سياقاتك اليوم بحسب آخر الإحصائيات
أن 45% من السعوديين يمتلكون مكتبات خاصة
مهما كان عدد المكتبات عندك أنت لا تقدر
أن تستوعب جميع هذه الكتب التي لا يرغب فيها
أصحابها لكن هل الحل
أنها تهمن؟ هل الحل أنها
تُصل؟ هذا الحاصل حالياً
لكن دورنا أنه في مشروع الآن
المفترض أنه يطلق في شهر
ثلاثة وتم العمل عليه وخذ وقت طويل
أطلقنا عليه منصة رفوف أن أي شخص يمتلك أي
كتاب يسلمه لهيئة
المكتبات هيئة المكتبات ستتيحها من خلال
منصة إلكترونية لأي شخص يطلبه بشكل مجاني
فقط يدفع رسوم التوصيل
فسيصبح عندكم مكتبة مركزية فيها
كل الكتب
هذا متى يبدأ؟
هذا انتهينا الآن خلاص أنا من
فرحة الاختبارات وشلون اعطيكم كتبي؟
كل الآليات راح تنزل تسلمها لأحد مكاتب
البريد أو حتى المندوب يأتي يسلمها منك
وتنزل على المنصة الخاصة
أنا في بيتي أدخل على المنصة هذه أشوف الكتب
التي أحتاجها أختار منها ربطنا مع شركة
توصيل تدفع رسوم التوصيل وتجي عندك
هذه النقطة الأولى لكن هناك ما يتعلق بالكتب
التي لا تعتبر نوادة أو المخطوطات بالنسبة
للنوادة والمخطوطات وهذا النقطة المهمة فيما
يتعلق بالمكتبات الخاصة
لا يوجد تصور أو حجم واضح عن حجم هذه
المقتنيات في المكتبات الخاصة خاصة للمتلكة
الأفراد ولما أعلنوا عنها قبل فترة
الجميع شاهد
وصار تداولة بشكل واسع في السوشيال ميديا
أحد الأشخاص يعرض مجموعة من المخطوطات
والمقتنات النادرة لأحد المتوفين فاليوم
عندنا مشروع في فهم المكتبات الخاصة
عندنا أيضًا من ضمن المكتبات
من ضمن مشروع المكتبة الرقمية بوابة
خاصة أو منصة خاصة للمكتبات الخاصة
هذه الآن موجودة
هذه ستطلق مع اطلاق المكتب الرقمي
ممتاز ، فيصير نافذة ، أي شيء
عندي صحيح أقدر أن أسلمكم إياه
لا ، هذه تعرض عليها
مثلًا ، أنا عندي كتب ، وهذه الكتب الموجودة
عندي لكنأساس أن نفهم حجم المكتبات
الخاصة والمختنيات الموجودة فيها
لكنالخطوة التي بعدها
هي أنه أحد يأتي ويشيل
إيه هذه موجودة من شهر ثلاثة ستكون مدشنة
هذا واحد يقول استعرضت كتاب قبل خمس سنوات
من المكتب العامة بالخرج وأعطوني مدة
سبوعين لأرجعها وأخذوا رقمي ولما انتهيت
من الكتب ورحت المكتب أرجعها وجدتها مغلقة
و وهذه أمانة أبغى أسلمها
الله يجزاك خير على أمانتك لكنطبعًا هذه شكلة
من ضمن الثمانين اللي
قفلتوها وشون وين يروح؟
بالعكس أول شيء الله يعطيه العافية
وأنا أعتقد أنه يرسل الهيئة
والهيئة تعالج الموضوع
وشو وسيلة المراسلة
موجود في حساباتنا على التواصل الاجتماعي
وموجودة أيضًا على موقع الهيئة
البريد الإلكتروني خاص بنا
واحد يقول ما هو دوركم
في تعزيز ثقافة القراءة
هذا كل شغلنا لتعزيز العادات القرائية كل
الشغل الذي تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل ويجعلها
عادة جاذبة هي كلها تصف في اللواء
لأن أحد اختصاصات هيئة المكتبات النص عليها
قرار إنشاء الهيئة التعزيز العادات القرائية
هناك سؤال لطيف ما الذي يجعل دول مثل أمريكا
و اليابان تجد فيها الناس في الأماكن العامة
يمسكون كتابة في المترو وفي القطار وفي
الباصات بينما مثلا
في العالم العربي أو في السعودية بالمناسبة
في السياق السعودي لا تجد مثلا
المشاهد ما السبب؟ أو ما التفسير؟
التفسير ببساطة أنه قضية السياقات الخاصة
في المشاريع التوعوية يعني اليوم خلنا نتكلم
على تجربة الآن موجودة عندنا في المكونات
السعودية إلى وقت قريب من كان يتوقع أنك
بتدخل المطعم بتشوف السعرات الحالية كم ما
كانت موجودة
اليوم مع مجهودات وزارة الصحة ورفع مستوى
الوعي الصحي لا صار فيه اختلاف في طريقة
التفكير اليوم هذا ما نتمنى
نتمنى أن نوصل إلى مرحلة أن القراءة تكون
ثقافة موجودة سواء كانت القراءة للمتعة
القراءة للتعلم وتطوير الذات القراءة
للإستكشاف وهذه بإذن الله تعالى ستنطلق
مع انطلاق مشاريع الهيئة
و لكن اعتقد أن مشاريع رؤية المملكة هي
الوقود وهي المحرك الأساسي لهذه الثقافة
هناك سؤال لطيف أتوقع أننا جوابنا عنه لكن
يبدو أنه سائل
تجربته رهيبة يقول أقضي ثلاث ساعات على
الأقل يومياً بين الكتب قرأت أكثر من ألف
كتاب أزور مكتبات العام متجاه في رياض لذلك
شهادتي إن شاء الله في محلها وأؤكد لك أن
أفضل مكان القراءة هي المقاهي وليس
المكتبات المكتبات سيئة قليلة متباعدة
ضعيفة غير فقر الكتب والأنشطة الموجودة
فيها فهذا واحد من أهم عملائكم صحيح وما هو
يأتيكم الوصف الذي وصفته في البيوت الثقافية
و كما قلت تصاميمك أيضًا أكيد
هو أشار نقطة جدًّا مهمة في قضية الكتب
و هذا أخذناه في الاعتبار في قضية بناء
المجموعات اليوم المجموعات الموجودة في أحدر
فيدر الوضع الطبيعي أنها تختلف عن المجموعات
الموجودة في الدمام تختلف
عن الموجودة في الرياض
بما يناسب
بما يناسب التوجهات الموجودة فاليوم بدأنا
بأعداد بسيطة في المكتبات ما بدأنا بأرقام
ضخمة يمكن المكتبات تستوعب إلى 50 ألف عنوان
اليوم بدأنا تقريبًا بـ 7 ألاف العنوان
الرئيسية بناء على توصيات وبناء
على دراسة السوق وأعلى الكتب مبيعا
بالمنطلق أنها كائن ينمو
كائن ينمو فبالتالي نتوقع أن خلال الفترة
القادمة أن نلبي احتياجات
القرى من مختلف الفروع المعرفة
أنا أختم بناصر بسؤال على الفرق بين مرحلتين
أنت كنت جزء من
وكالة الثقافة المعنية بالمكتبات
قبل الرؤية وأنت اليوم تقود هيئة المكتبات
بشكل جديد بعد الرؤية ما هو الفرق بين
مرحلتين؟ وما هو المشروع الذي كنت تحلم به
في ذلك المرحلة ولم تستطع
تحققها إلا في هذه المرحلة؟
حسناً، حسناً،
ربما أقول لك شيء يمكن أن تتفاجأ منه
مشروع تطويل المكتبات العامة
اشتغلت عليه في 2017 عندما كنت في الوزارة
وزارة الإعلام
وكان بحسب الإمكانيات المتاحة
وطلبت ميزانية 12 مليون ريال
لإجراء بعض الأشياء البسيطة
وكان من ضمن الأشياء التي
كنت أركز كل جهدي في ذلك الفترة على موضوع
المكتبات
لأنني مؤمن أنه سيحدث نقلة كبيرة فيما يتعلق
بجودة حياة وتنمية قدرات البشرية
حسن الحظ أني لما جيت للوزارة الثقافة طبعا
أنا جيت للوزارة الثقافة كمدير معرض الرياض
الدولي كتاب 2020 أنا ما جيت كرئيس تنفيذي
فكان من ضمن الأوراق أو من ضمن النقل
الاختصاص اللي هو الملفات اللي نقلت للوزارة
فلما طلعت عليها
جدت الذكريات
طبعًا لم يعتمد المشروع ذاك
لا أعتمد لكنها أدخلت من ضمن
لم يمثل 80% من ميزانية كل قطاع الثقافة نعم
لكن كان على عدد محدد لم يكن على المكتبات
كلها نعم لكن كان له تأثير في قضية إدراج
المكتبات العامة ضمن مشاريع
برنامج جودة الحياة كان له علاقة
كبيرة أنه أدرج المكتبات من ضمن البرنامج
لأنه لو تشاهد برنامج جودة الحياة، فهناك
سيكشن خاص في المكتبات العامة اليوم الوضع
مختلف تمامًا أول شيء أنت
جزء من من استراتيجية وطنية للثقافة
استراتيجية هذه مبنية على رؤية المملكة 2030
تطلعات الناس اختلفت
الظروف اختلفت التشريعات والأنظمة اختلفت
يعني 2017 لم يكن هناك برنامج جودة الحياة
لم يكن هناك برنامج جودة الحياة وكنا نتكلم
عنه في برنامج سمية قدرات
البشرية كل هذه لم تكن موجودة فاليوم العمل
أصبح أكثر متعة وأصعب قليلا
لكن إن شاء الله قادرين
لأنه لم يعد لكم عذر لم
يعد لنا
عذر أول ما
كان هناك موكنات فهي يعني
لكن اليوم كل ما كانت موجودة
أنا أذكر أحد الأشخاص
سوينا إستطلاع عن المكتبات
فكان من ضمن الردود التي وصلت
احنا نكتب في ضمن السؤال إن شاء الله ستتحقق
فكاتب تحت الوعد 20-20
كنا نقول 20-20 كفر طبعًا نشاوز الثقافة
ففعليًّا عندما رجعت ووجدت كاتب 20-20
فعليًّا المسؤولية تكون مضاعفة
كيف نقدر نقدم لأنه في الأخير اليوم عندك
فرصة أعطيت هذا الـ 516
هدية لأحد هداية القطاع الثقافي ودعمت بكل
قوة مالياً وإدارياً فلا عذر لأنك لم تقدم
فنأمل أن نحقق مستهدف وتجربة أحد الفيادة
تتكرر في جميع المكتبات
العامة وبيوت الثقافة
دعونا ننتهي بالسؤال كيف نقيص
نجاحكم؟ متى نقول أن الهيئة نجحت؟
هناك أكثر من مؤشر
أولاً عدد الزيارات بالنسبة للمكتبات هذا
مؤشر مهم جدًّا الشيء الثاني هو حركة
تداول أوعية المعلومات، ومعدلات الإعارة ترتفع
أيضًا أعتقد أن لنا دور مهم في قضية
تحسين العادات القرائية
وطلبنا الآن عندنا مشروع في أحد الرفيدا نبغى نسوي
دراسة قبلية عن الأطفال في أحد رفيدا
وبعد سنة نقيس مستوى القراءة عند الأطفال
فهذه هي المؤشرات اللي راح تحكمنا
بالإضافة إلى المؤشرات التشغيلية الثانية اللي هو قضية
تعزيز إيرادات بيوت ثقافة
التمويل، ومصادر التمويل وغيرها
لكن الزيارات، والفعاليات كم عدد الأشخاص
اللي تستهويهم فعاليات هيئة المكتبات
خاصة الموجهة، فهذه راح تكون مؤشرات
عساك مع القوة
شكرًا يا أبو ناصر شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يحفظك، وشكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم، الله يعطيكم العافية
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لفهد القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
عبدالرحمن العطاس في إدارة التصوير.
وفي الإضاءة: إسماعيل شوقي وسعيد عمر.
وفي تسجيل الصوت: عبد الرزاق المزي.
وفي التحرير: مرامض بيبان.
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن
وإدارة الإنتاج: عبد المجيد عمر.
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: غيداء التميم.
هذا سقراط أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع